les etats unis annoncent en accord avec
le gouvernement allemand pour clore la
dispute au sujet du gazoduc north stream
2 reliant la russie à l'allemagne
un accord qui menacent l'ukraine et
l'europe centrale juge qui avait
varsovie qui ont immédiatement réagi lé
détail avec notre correspondant à moscou
antoine gayraud moscou ne peut que se
réjouir d'une telle annonce après des
années de sanctions visant la
finalisation du chantier
dans un entretien téléphonique avec
angela merkel vladimir poutine s'est
félicité de cette annonce il a également
souligné le soutien constant de berlin
dans ce dossier tout au long de ces
années et cet accord vient avec des
conditions comme l'annoncé la sous
secrétaire d'état américaine victoria
nuland
en effet la russie s'exposerait à des
sanctions si elles venaient à je cite
tenté d'utiliser l'énergie comme une
arme ou commettre des actes agressifs
envers l'ukraine est toujours à propos
de l'ukraine berlin et washington
souhaitent faire prolonger de dix ans le
transit du gaz russe via le territoire
ukrainien sergey lavrov s'est exprimé
sur ce sujet quelques minutes avant
cette annonce officielle j'ai entendu
dire que ces négociations seraient
achevés je préfère attendre l'annoncé
officielle
'l'annonce devrait tomber aujourd'hui
mais d'après les fuites dans les médias
on est frappé si c'est vrai par l'accord
selon lequel l'allemagne s'engagerait
assurer le transit du gaz russe vers
l'ukraine après 2024 on pourrait penser
que l'allemagne est forte on verra
comment cela sera finalement finalisé
même si la russie se méfie de ce genre
de conditions suspensives
c'est un soulagement de voir ce dossier
épineux trouver enfin une issue
favorable
la nouvelle n'a par contre pas été bien
accueillie à kiev qui juge que cela crée
de nouvelles menaces pour l'ukraine où
le 10 mai rosaline ce qui sera
d'ailleurs reçu par joe biden à la
maison blanche le 30 août prochain